[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
so
to
[Music]
so
hey here we are we're live yeah
yeah last night was quite a show
i'm like afraid to watch it back home no
it was good it's all right
it was all right she thinks she she
thinks she didn't actually do the show
that she didn't do it
i woke up like in them but well i woke
up i'm sleepy
today i'm not actually hungover which is
amazing but um
yeah i'm sleepy today because you were
snoring and it woke me up at four in the
morning and i couldn't go back to sleep
because it was really loud
but um yes i kept like poking him like
stop snoring
yeah well that last hour you know you
started fading out you know you had you
had people in the [ __ ] comment
section laughing like ah jenny's gone
she's like i know
but you you did you did finish it i did
i had yeah i had to [ __ ] kind of
pride you along um
i know jenny real well you know well
yeah she's like spock
she's pretty concise and she gets to the
point but
when she starts to get drunk she starts
going circular well she'll kind of say
the same things over and over again you
know what i mean so you kind of have to
okay what happened next
oh okay and then she moves on so you
kind of went circular
not not so bad that i don't think that
other people noticed it but i noticed it
okay i don't think it wasn't that bad
just you started to kind of
expound and explain it to it and it's
like it's funny because like now you got
to come on you go
keep keep going you know and then and we
were we were four hours into it
all right it ended up being a form and
you had a couple little paragraphs that
you wanted to talk about yeah i think
but i had to just say okay well what
happened what happened at the trial and
you know
and we were able to cover like they're
pretty much all dead now yeah yeah
well the funny thing about it is that i
did not i when i woke up
like i felt okay like amazingly yeah but
um i couldn't remember i didn't remember
ending the show
i didn't remember if i had eaten
anything no i tried to feed you
and then and then earlier today
he brings in a chicken salad sandwich
with one bite taken out of it
he's like i brought this to you last
night and i asked you if you wanted it
and you took one bite and said no i
didn't want it and then like left it on
the bed yeah you just slipped on it
so he put it in the bag and put it at
the fridge i did not remember that
at all i see you're not you're not
hungry and she goes i don't want it
really i should have eaten it probably
but i felt okay this morning though
because even though i think that
um i didn't eat before the show the last
thing i'd eaten was that
bowl of beef stew at like 11 or 12 and
that's like i don't think i'd eaten
we you know once i was once i was
watching you you know what i mean that
lasts like 20 minutes or so
i kind of had to [ __ ] keep you moving
um because i i know how she is and i
know how jenny is
she she gets to a certain
when she's drunk she's fun but if she
starts getting real drunk she starts to
become a combative
and very very sleepy yeah she's real
sleepy and combative
she thinks you're picking on her then it
starts to go
of like you're [ __ ] with me and i'm
not on fire and then it's you don't love
me
and then it's just and she'll start
[ __ ] spiraling out of control so
i was saying we're gonna have to end
this show because she's gonna turn
around go you [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't
love me
she probably would have just followed
yeah yeah i probably would why
it's just i was just getting really
sleepy yeah and then when she wakes up
she doesn't remember but she'll
she'll go whoa as me on on you
in those [ __ ] final few minutes of
[ __ ] consciousness and then she
[ __ ]
sleeps yeah yeah i was just amazed that
i felt like
okay when i woke up i was like i said
i'm just sleepy but that's because you
were snoring at night woke me up
in the morning and then and then i woke
up and i was like wait i don't remember
finishing the show i'm like is pookie
inside
where's spooky and then i kept like
smacking the side of the bed i'm like
hey
i was trying not to wake you up i was
like hey pokey yeah hey pokey
and then like she jumped up on the bed
and i was like oh there you are yeah
she's like what what my mommy over here
yeah she's a good girl she comes when
you call most of the time so ac went out
yesterday
uh from b's nest people saying it was a
good show
a lot of people have hangovers uh
so yeah we do the show and [ __ ] the
audience is getting sloshed with us
that's good that makes me feel a little
bit better it's saturday night because i
was kind of like having anxiety like
what the [ __ ]
like did i even finish the show did we
even talk about the topic i was like
yeah
i felt like we did it
had to skip you had yeah skim over a
little bit it would have taken another
hour
after at the rate you were going in the
at the final [ __ ]
15-20 minutes yeah if i didn't hurry it
up it would have gone for another hour
yeah um it's just you're
yeah you were expounded on it like three
times every little point you'd [ __ ]
explain it one way and then you come
back and you explain that another way
and then you come over and explain it
this way and like they got it they got
it jenny what's the web
you know because that's what you do i
know that's that's how you do when
you're [ __ ] loaded
yeah i got i think it i didn't drink
like
any more than usual but i think it's
just because i hadn't eaten
so i think it like affected me more than
so probably i should have eaten before i
went to sleep but
yeah yeah of course you know yeah we
were [ __ ] sidetracking what a [ __ ]
i was sidetracking we were both side
tracking the show we uh yeah we are
and then uh saying i wake up with a bomb
collar
yeah oh i wanted to say uh i wanted to
give a shout out to
to sandra still here to the duct tape
and also to jason
uh who sent us paypal donations today
yeah matter of fact we got
shirts on order they're gonna be here
yeah the the people that um
the two people last night was mark and
uh victor that wanted shirts
i ordered the blanks today so the blanks
will be here tuesday so we'll print them
and
get them mailed before the end of the
week yeah we'll send them out next week
yeah so that'll so you'll have them soon
yeah take long um so we're gonna talk
about
a movie today yeah this one was off
shatter
yeah this was shutter just added this
one this is actually a dutch
slash flemish movie a new movie from
2020 i think it came out in
march of this year and it's called
uncaged
yeah this is a pretty good movie i
actually really liked it it's kind of
like a horror comedy
i guess yeah it's almost 80s style like
an animal attack
yeah type movie it's a horror comedy
movie though yeah
i thought it was pretty funny yeah and
kind of like animal disaster
type theme i would say traditional
storytelling
80s 80s style um
it's got some cg in it to do the lion
yeah it's about a killer lion yeah a
man-eating lion yeah and there's a bunch
of twists in it so we're not gonna spoil
it
i won't but i will give i will give like
a brief overview of the plot now
there oh hold on i want to say something
what's that there there is cg
in it the cg is not all that epic um
but it doesn't matter because it's good
enough the tone of the story
makes it good enough and then there's a
lot of uh practical effects for the gore
so
it works out and it was i think the um
the cgi for the lion like when it was
cgi shots because i think they used
puppets and some in some of the shots
to the picture yeah but um the cgi that
they used was about equivalent to
what that thai movie with the yeah
called the pool
crocodile or whatever so it's like it's
not perfect but that's good enough but
it was good enough for
what they were uh doing the tone of the
movie is not
ultra realism so it doesn't really
matter yeah
like i said it's a horror comedy it kind
of reminded me
like not not in subject matter really
but
tonally it reminded me of gremlins kind
of yeah
like where it was like a comedy but it
was also like super
gory and like really violent kind of
like a mixture of gremlins and [ __ ]
jurassic park in a way you know instead
of a runaway dinosaurs as runaway
[ __ ] lion
it's a lion in the middle of europe and
[ __ ]
weird comedic characters trying to stop
a damn line
and it's in the movies in dutch and in
english
yeah because what ends up happening it's
set in amsterdam
and um most of the like for the first
half of the movie it's pretty much all
in
uh dutch and then they introduce a
british
character and at that end he speaks
english and everyone speaks english to
him
so at that point it becomes like a
mixture of dutch and english um
but yeah so the basic premise of the
story
is that your main character is this
woman named lizzie and she's like a
veterinarian she
works at the amsterdam zoo and
at the very beginning there's a lion
attack i mean
saying it's a lion that's not a spoiler
because there's a lion on the poster so
it's like everybody knows what it is
so uh this lion attacks like this whole
family and like kills this whole family
like in a really really gory like
graphic
way and they can tell that it's an
animal so
they call her in to kind of like
investigate or like help them
yeah the funny thing about the poster of
the show is the show lying on there it
looks like a mutant lion with two
different eyes and [ __ ]
i thought it was gonna be like prophecy
some kind of [ __ ] mutant line
i was waiting for that but it's
deceptive it's just a lion
pretty much i think the only thing that
they say about it is that
it's bigger than a normal lion and
it's a man-eater yeah and why
was that i think i might have missed
that point i'm not really sure if they
like specified where the lion king i
think the only thing that they said
about where the lion came from was that
it was uh like when the hunter came and
he was talking about
uh namibia or whatever wherever he had
been and he said that this was maybe one
of those lions and he's like oh he's a
long way from home or something like
that yeah but so it's not genetically
engineered or anything
no i don't think so i didn't catch that
either yeah i'm pretty sure it was just
like a regular
just a big one yeah you could tell i
wasn't paying a
whole real super close attention to the
movie i was enjoying it
and a lot of times when i enjoy a movie
i don't really pay it close it is dude
well it's just a fun it's just a fun
movie
yeah and there's a lot of subtitles and
sometimes i was looking away wouldn't
didn't quite catch
what they had said right but it does
it's not really
doesn't really matter it's it's actually
an action movie
pretty basically action comedy slash
horror
a bunch of [ __ ] good it had good
practical gore effects
yeah i really liked like the gore was
like really really good people's heads
getting bit off
and all kinds of stuff uh car wrecks and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] uh what else the guys running
around the bus
the lion on the bus yeah lying on the
bus that was great um
[ __ ] um traps for the lions they're
like those big [ __ ]
[ __ ] claw traps and [ __ ] with the
teeth on them and [ __ ] but guys falling
i'm gonna get bit in half by the dab
traps
just you know it's all right it's a good
movie yeah it's like i said it was super
fun
yeah um just kind of like an
old-fashioned uh
you know horror comedy real gory um you
know kind of funny
characters like caricature type
characters yeah
um you know what i mean and also i like
that they didn't shy away from like
you know little kids getting killed by
the lion and like nothing like that you
know yeah there's some twists and some
surprises
to the story too you know what i mean
about the lion but we're not gonna
[ __ ]
not gonna spoil it yeah and i'm like i
said so so lizzy's the main character
she's got like kind of an on-again
off-again boyfriend named dave
and uh he's like a media guy i guess
he's like a camera news cameraman or
something like that
he's kind of saw it out he's a soy boy
and well he's kind of well he's kind of
like annoying yeah
sort of um and like he also is a horn
dog and like cheats on her all the time
with
like that that was one of the funny
scenes we're taking pictures of like
yeah he's like a porn director yeah he
was doing he was doing poor direction on
the side
like and the pimps were [ __ ] trying
to whip his ass because he was
he was [ __ ] doing porn scenes with
the pimp's girlfriends and [ __ ] and then
not publishing the porn just keeping it
that was the that was part of yeah she
was kind of like a throwaway joke but
yeah yeah
but yeah so what ends up happening is
that the
it's kind of like um parodying i guess
how it had like a very jaws feel to it
too where it's like the
authorities didn't want to tell anybody
that there was a lion running around
um because they thought no one would
believe them and then like when they did
tell the media the media didn't believe
them and everyone just laughed at them
and thought it was stupid
um but then like as the attack started
to pile up like obviously they had to
take it more seriously then
yeah and then they bring in a hunter
who's like the chief of police's
nephew or brother or something like that
and he's like [ __ ] jack black or some
[ __ ]
yeah that element of the story kind of
reminds me right reminded me of like a
70s
uh of disaster disaster movie it it had
like
yeah i liked that part of the story too
and then it goes on and it becomes kind
of like an action
horror yeah yeah it's good with comedy
in it it's good
and then they bring in um this other
hunter
like the who's british and who also
happens to be like
the ex-boyfriend of the main character
lizzy so there's like
all this tension between the new
boyfriend and the old boyfriend and that
guy
that character was like kind of the best
character like the british guy
um that comes in and i'm not gonna spoil
his character either because it's pretty
funny but yeah
this is like a really good i don't know
how low budget it was or anything like
that but it just seemed like a really
good
fun you know horror comedy lots of funny
[ __ ] in it
lots and lots of gore um you know the
cgi is not
perfect but it was like good enough it
was better than the tiger on the walking
dead i'll say that
oh yeah
[Laughter]
poor walking dead boy we haven't seen
that we haven't seen the new season
i haven't watched it we might have
missed two seasons of that as far as i
know um
no i think we just missed one season um
but like i said i'll have to go back i
was gonna wait until
netflix had it and then just like watch
the whole thing at once
so because i might have to watch the
last season too because i kind of forgot
what happened and i missed some
episodes yeah that one that series was
really starting to get kind of boring
i don't know i was talking to michael
from a starry night and he because
um when the season this last season was
on and he said that it had gotten like a
whole lot better
like especially with the whisperers and
stuff okay so
i don't know but i haven't seen it lost
its hard edge and i haven't you know and
i hadn't really been keeping up with
what was going on with it or anything
what's up pukes
hey pookie she's gonna jump up on top
she's going to jump up she thought about
it and then she's like
i'll do it later maybe i'll do it did
she like stick her butt in the camera
last night or anything
i don't uh i don't think so i can't
remember if she did or not
i just couldn't remember if she was oh
oh oh she's coming she here she goes
here she goes
nope never she's going to try to get it
from another angle she's coming she's
going to jump
up from this angle okay please please
don't do food
there she is yeah there she is
running behind her she's looking in all
the coffee cups yeah
see if there's something to eat yeah is
that something for pokey no that's not
for pokey she doesn't like there's
anything else
on top of this movie um i don't think so
um
shutter added another new one too which
we will probably review i'll probably
watch it tonight we can maybe review
that one tomorrow i can't remember what
it's called
i think it's found footage yeah um but
yeah so shutter's been adding some new
[ __ ] and that's pretty cool
and uh this is a real good one you know
if you it's worth watching it's
definitely worth watching like i said
yeah there's people in the comments
section saying that they have shout out
that they like the service you know and
thanking us for i guess recommending it
yeah somebody um just contacted me on
facebook today uh
robert i think and he said that he's in
australia and they just got shutter
hey that's spooky's little tail yeah
she's already jumped back down you can
jump you can make it you can jump it's
not far come on
she didn't want me to help her oh she's
like oh yeah i can do it so australia
just got it they just got it
and uh he said he really liked it like
um he's like there's a really good
selection and it's like
not expensive no it's cheap it's cheap
and it's got all the [ __ ] good horror
movies on it yeah
and i mean like i said i don't i don't
know um because i know that there's
rights differences so i don't know if
like because i know the uk shutter has
different [ __ ]
that at least it did it did for a while
but i've heard that the uk one is
actually getting better like with
like a wider selection and stuff and
like i said if you have like a vpn you
can probably watch the american shutter
yeah i would think american shutter has
almost everything it looks seemed like
they have i mean like i said between
shutter
tubie and netflix you can watch
pretty much whatever horror movie you
wanted and every now and then sometimes
we have to like rent one
off of youtube or off the xbox or
whatever but
i don't you know old or new i don't
usually have a lot of problem finding
anything between those three services
which is why i don't ever you know get
any other ones
another good thing about shutters and
we're not we're not plugging shutter
because they pay us we're you know
that's not a sponsor we wish
i wish it they were a sponsor they i see
some
uh channels that they do sponsor i think
you have to be like pretty big yeah
yeah we're probably not big enough but i
wish uh yeah but um they have a couple
of original series that are really good
yeah um we saw which one what which one
was yours well they had they
they had the creep show the creep show
one that's what i was thinking uh they
have the joe bob briggs
yeah driving theater that was that's a
good one they also show i did this isn't
their
uh this isn't their series but um it's
oh [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] is it it's the
one where they
each season is like different
creepypasta i actually think that they
did started that on the sci-fi channel
yeah but they have all the seasons on
shutter they have some good
documentaries on there too
they have all the italian dialogues they
have a bunch of giant movies
um yeah there's a bunch of them on all
the phantasms i think are all there
all of them except two two i think
are on there at the moment yeah scotch
and dario argento on there
probably most of the friday the 13th
maybe maybe all of them
i don't know if those are still on there
they were just on there for like uh
um for a limited time because remember
we
that's when we reviewed they they added
like all like the first eight of them or
something yeah
um but yeah they added a bunch of more
like old slashers the other day they
added like um
maniac sleep away camp um mad man there
was like a whole bunch of the old like
slasher movies they added all of those
as well
yeah um and like i said they added
patrick which is why we reviewed it the
other day
they also added i don't know if maybe
one of these days we'll review this one
too but they also added beyond the door
which is like an italian
man it's an italian exorcist robot we
gotta see that
yeah it's a they added that the other
day too i'll tell you what when i was a
kid
my babysitter kimmy took us took me to
see i think it was uh
because it dirt to the matinee i think
it was uh
anthonyville [ __ ] might have been
amityville [ __ ] and
and and the trailer for that beyond the
door
was [ __ ] played before the amityville
horror i believe it might have been
another horror movie
because she took me to see so many up
yeah i don't know how they got me into
it it was the seventies
you could get a kid yeah yeah they're
already like they didn't give [ __ ]
as long as you're with somebody that
looked old enough that's yeah and kimmy
wasn't she was like a
14 year old princess leia 13 years old
she wasn't old enough probably to be in
an r-rated movie
um that [ __ ] trailer
from beyond the door scared the [ __ ] out
of me as a little kid
the woman [ __ ] floating through the
sky and all the [ __ ] furniture
[ __ ] flying around the green
green and blue lights inside the house
and [ __ ] [ __ ] shining through the
[ __ ] shades
and beyond the door and i remember that
[ __ ] to this day yeah
yeah i got to see that again yeah i
never saw it but
you know what i mean i you saw the i saw
just the trailer the trailer and just
the trailer
scared the [ __ ] out of me i could
remember remember if i've ever seen you
said that as soon as you said that the
trailer [ __ ] came back to me
yeah yeah yeah
i loved kevin man i had a huge crush on
her i shot a picture every once in a
while she was 13 or 13 or 14 you looked
just like princess leia and how old were
you at that time
maybe about five okay six oh
seven something it's hard to say two
years what year was that
when amityville horror came out 1979.
okay so it wasn't any of the [ __ ] it
was a lot younger when did beyond the
door come out
ooh i don't know i saw the trailer 74
75 okay so that must have been about i
saw six
yeah okay so that makes more sense so
but i
i thought somebody took me to see
ebonyville horror it must not have been
her
yeah i'm pretty sure that was 1979.
yeah the amityville horror came out yeah
and i'd already moved away from
from the block in which i lived at kimi
li we lived on the same block so i
already moved away by 79 1974 victor
says
what uh yeah okay so i was five okay
yeah so you were right the first time i
was five she's probably about 13. i
believe i totally i said 1974 1935. yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
that wasn't even hilarious yeah you
didn't know they they just added that
like the other day i think they added at
the same time that they added patrick
too i bet you if i were to see that
trailer again it's probably not scary at
all
it's probably not probably [ __ ] silly
as [ __ ] well that's the thing it's like
i'm always kind of interested in [ __ ]
that i
found really scary when i was little and
then like you see it later and you're
just like
that's it what was i thinking yeah do
you know i don't know if i've ever
mentioned this before but do you know
what used to scare the [ __ ] out of me
when i was a little bitty
kid for some reason was you know the
song monster mash
yeah you know the cauldron bubbling
sound effect at the beginning that used
to scare the
[ __ ] crap out of me and i don't know
why like every time
i liked the song yeah but i couldn't
listen to that noise
like i had to like run out of the
[ __ ] room whatever and then i would
come back in like after that part was
done
i don't know why i think i've told this
story before on the show i don't know
we're not
gonna see what everybody's saying see if
there's any questions or anything okay
the uh
there when i was growing up in
california and during that same
era that i'm talking about and i think
it was around 76 or 77
76 because it was before star wars
and i remember the bicentennial
happening around that time
on channel in california on channel 22.
it's called vhf 22 or uhf 22.
uhf 22. they had a vhf [ __ ] knob in
the uhf
the uhf that was all the [ __ ] big
numbers it's all a little static
kids you guys remember that kids don't
even know what kids don't even know what
static is we had to pick up
tv on down [ __ ] rabbit ears and [ __ ]
broadcast television and uh on channel
22
in california at that time was the uh
japanese channel
because the largest [ __ ] community of
[ __ ] japanese expats
outside of japan was in california at
that time yeah they were
descendants of wine makers and [ __ ] all
that [ __ ]
giulio gallo [ __ ] spanish and italian
[ __ ] it's all japanese making that in
california
anyway they had a series on there that
they would that
they played after school when i would
come home and i
it's around the time i was watching
ghetto robo and grindeizer they had
those on
after all that they had a live action
show one of them was go ranger
that was later though it was the power
rangers yeah that was around 77
78 around that time i think but
they had another one though that scared
the [ __ ] out of me
and it was a live-action series
about this dude in in feudal japan
but i didn't know what feudal japan was
i had no idea what it was i was watching
it was just people with knives
and swords with [ __ ] funny hats
in these funny-looking paper houses and
[ __ ] with fire
lanterns and [ __ ] i had no idea they
were showing me the past in another
in japan i knew japan but i thought that
was japan now
you know what i mean thank you celtic
angel thank you very much bro
so this guy in feudal japan
would jump into a well and then
come flying up out of the well with
with a white demonic face and a huge
white [ __ ] hair and a horn sticking
out of his head
with all these [ __ ] weapons and
spears
and then a horse would run out of the
[ __ ]
forest run to him and the horse [ __ ]
had a unicorn horn and [ __ ] fangs
and he would jump on it and he was
fighting
flying umbrellas that was a
yokai monster they were yokai monsters i
i had no idea what i was [ __ ]
watching i was totally feeling like
somebody and it was scaring the [ __ ] out
of me
there was a scene where there were
people planting stuff
out in a field and out of the sky came
flying [ __ ] umbrellas and the
umbrellas had mouths on them and eyes
and they were shooting poison darts out
of their [ __ ] mouths they killed all
those people
and then they flew away and the dude saw
that and he jumped into the [ __ ] well
and came out a demon
and no one looking back on it now what
it was is he came out like a kabuki
samurai
right that's what he came out that's
what i pictured and he had a demon horse
that [ __ ] would come and he would
jump on it like the lone ranger and he
went [ __ ] running off over these
flying umbrellas
and a bunch of weird [ __ ] happened over
time in this series and every time
i would a new episode of this series
would come out
something more terrifying would be shown
one of them was a two-legged monster
with a whole bunch of [ __ ]
tentacles coming out the top of it and
the tentacles were made out of hair
and where the titties would be with eyes
and the bottom legs was running around
and it was [ __ ] snatching people on
its belly had a huge mouth full of teeth
and it was [ __ ] eating people
it was a woman in a costume but when
you're a kid you're like [ __ ]
it was just terrifying where boobs was
she had these big old eyes
and then where her belly was his huge
[ __ ] mouth and her hand was up inside
this thing with all this fake hair it
was great like tentacles grabbing dudes
it was [ __ ]
shoving them in her belly and the way it
was filmed you know what i mean when
you're like seven you're like bite into
it you're like oh
[ __ ] and for the life of me i can't i
can't find what that series is
it was something japanese yeah i've
looked for it
you guys are so weird some kind of
japanese
some kind of japanese feudal era was it
a kids show
or was it just like a regular show no it
was uh cause i was like man that's
pretty hardcore
it was kid's show
looking back on it it was like a more
serious version of the power rangers
okay you know i mean it was a little
like a live action one right
but it was my it probably was like power
rangers
because people got killed in the power
rangers too did they i don't i never
watched the power rangers that was a
little
i think they did well the go rangers i
think they did people got blown up with
bombs and [ __ ]
yeah and people went flying it was
something like that it had a horror
element to it
a lot of [ __ ] that was happening was
happening at night
it was kind of like yokai wars yeah that
movie i thought for a while that that
might have been it but that wasn't it
this was a series
and the dude that would jump out he was
all [ __ ] white with [ __ ] this
red makeup red eyes painted around like
the only thing i could [ __ ] equate it
to at the time is that he came out like
gene simmons from kiss that's what he
looked like
that's what he looked like but he had a
red face instead of all that black
right you know like a red [ __ ] makeup
on white red on white
jane simmons with a huge white wig that
stood about two feet tall on top
and about three feet either direction of
his head now remember it almost touching
the ground
that's how big that [ __ ] wig was like
a kabuki actor right
and he's wearing [ __ ] samurai outfit
and he had [ __ ]
a thing called a like a big spear with a
curved blade on it
i think it's called a uh okay yeah i
can't remember this [ __ ] it's
then swords and and a [ __ ] demon
horse
does it does this ring a bell with
anybody in the damn
comment sections do you have any idea
what because that sounds pretty cool we
need the leg
yeah i'm trying to find it we need to
find that
i can see how like seeing that as a kid
would probably like scar you for life
though i mean i can remember to this day
yeah that's what i mean that's like some
scary [ __ ] i just it's
it's just funny how i don't know like
how
scary and weird like [ __ ] is when you're
a kid and then you see it later
well i didn't have any kind of cultural
context right because to you it was just
like these kind of random like what the
hell is even going on with the umbrellas
yeah flying umbrellas [ __ ] titty
monsters
with belly teeth and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
the blades and no electricity i didn't
know i was being shown something from
the past
you know a story that was supposed to
come from the past past i thought it was
just a faraway place where people
had problems with umbrellas killing
people yeah i mean
man where is this i was just like
watching some it was
for me at that time that's why you know
all these little japanese robots that i
have back here you know
experiencing that stuff from an american
perspective where you don't really speak
the
the language you're just watching the
programs and when you're a kid
it's so alien it makes a big impression
on you yeah
and that was like that was on par with
like uh the robots that was on par with
like superheroes
yeah i could easily understand what was
going on there i loved all the [ __ ]
the robots and the ufos and the aliens
and the explosions
but no that that yokai [ __ ]
monster [ __ ] series [ __ ] me up i
didn't have a cultural context for it
yeah like i said it sounds pretty scary
yeah like especially when you're a kid
yeah it's funny because when i was
growing up um on cable they used to show
this animated
jack and the beanstalk all the time and
it really so i really liked it but it
really like creeped me out because it
was like it was kind of like the regular
jack and the beanstalk story but then
there was like a little princess with
like the big eyes and then
there was the giant named tulip and the
giant was like kind of controlled by
this little witch
named madame hecuba who was like his mom
yeah you know what's funny
i already told you this but my ex-wife
was way into that [ __ ] cartoon and i
saw it
like a bunch of times when i was a kid
and then like i kind and it made a big
impression
and then i kind of forgot about i'm like
did that really happen or was it just
like a fever dream or something because
it was like some really weird like
psychedelic [ __ ] in there
so i looked it up later and i found it
and it turns out which i didn't know at
the time
it turns out that it was japanese yeah
and it was dubbed into english and that
didn't occur to me like when i was a kid
watching it i didn't know that it was
originally japanese i didn't know
like you know what the whole like
[ __ ] thing was so it's like oh well
that actually kind of explains a lot
like why they why they added like these
strange elements to it
um but i can't remember what the
japanese title of it is
it's uh i looked it up one time but i
remember when you said madam heck about
the [ __ ] jack and the beanstalk
element
i remember my my ex-wife had that on vhs
tape
yeah and i just thought she saw it as a
kid and it disturbed her and
and she kept weird yeah that's what she
said she played some of it for me and it
was kind of weird
it's weird but i was you know i was uh
25 at the time that she showed it to me
yeah and really what was what i remember
just off the top of my head what was
weird about it
was the tone of the musical score behind
what was happening a lot of the [ __ ]
didn't really
match up and there was some stuff
robotic [ __ ] had happened with some of
the characters
madame hecuba it turns out at the end
when the giant steps on her spoiler
alert
yeah she's a robot yeah yeah springs and
robots and didn't she watch and they
don't
explain it right right right like why
she's a robot she just is
it's it's because the japanese would
like certain stories
that were western but they reboot them
with japanese elements that
can don't really translate too well to
american culture because their
influences are from another set of
[ __ ] literature
another set of cartoons that were
popular at the time
that that audience had seen so that
audience was used to certain things
happening
like uh there was a [ __ ] super sentai
robot you know what i mean that was what
that what was that fucker's name
it was a cool looking robot it was kind
of like power rangers
and it was spider-man yeah okay in japan
spider-man had a giant robot that he got
into kind of like the old series
johnny sacco and giant robot in japan
you couldn't sell the concept of a
marvel superhero to a kid
to a japanese kid they were like okay
they don't even have a robot he doesn't
have a robot though what the [ __ ]
how super can he be yeah like okay
he can climb on the walls he can shoot
webs he's got spider dna
where's his robot superheroes always
have a gigantic [ __ ] robot
it goes all the way back to you know
gojira you know or godzilla is known as
here you know it's something that's
really big
so a superhero just doesn't play out
well i don't remember the name
of what japanese spider-man's robot was
but really the robot was the star
of japanese spider-man series not
not not spider-man yeah because he's
just a dude
yeah he was kind of like a he just was
piling in it
he could do stuff and he did do stuff
like spider-man
but only for a few seconds then he would
jump in that big robot and he would
fight another bad guy who had a big
robot who had a big robot yeah
because if you know if the bad guy has a
big robot then you have
everybody has to have a big robot that's
just basically and we inherited that
same [ __ ] from [ __ ] power rangers
yeah that's they do the same thing they
fight in person for a few minutes and
then they jump in the damn
planes and then the planes then the
planes combined into a [ __ ] giant
robot
then they have to fight it because the
bad guy got really big
yeah and somehow the bad guy always gets
real big because some some witch shows
up and [ __ ] hits him
[Laughter]
if you guys read a review of that movie
it's so good it's so good
it's almost kind of like i don't want to
say it's like a parody
of it but it kind of is it's like a
parody of like this kind of
kaiju type of movies where yeah but he
gets really big like to fight all these
different monsters like these wacky
big giant monsters that oh i remember i
remember the name of japanese
spider-man's robot
is his robot was named leopoldeon
that's awesome leopoldian that's what
his name is
that's so random and leopoldian was
really the star of japanese spider-man
not spider-man
yeah yeah he was just some dude he was a
dude like something off the power
rangers that just jumped around into you
at united
yeah yes
so imagine you're american right
and you got this new series of
spider-man you're going to watch
it's all been dubbed into english it
looks like [ __ ]
marvel spider-man it's got [ __ ] what
what's his name on the back of the dude
[ __ ] stan lee and [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] spider-man and then when
you see it
it's giant robots and it's the [ __ ]
power rangers it just has to happen spot
it just
has spider-man outfit yeah so you're
gonna be
[ __ ] up well that's the way that's
that's just how japan's gonna sell you
jack and the beanstalk too they're gonna
do that same [ __ ]
well you know how there's a whole um
industry in
turkey of ripping off like american
superhero
movies and actually actually any movie
that's like pretty because um
brandon tennold he's a canadian guy that
has like a really good
uh channel where he reviews like crappy
movies and sometimes good ones
but um he's done like a whole series
of turkish knockoff movies like there's
a turkish batman robin
there's a turkish star wars there's a
turkish everything
and they are so so terrible funny
they're so funny they actually make
modern versions of that in turkey those
rip offs that are made to be funny on
purpose yeah that oh my
gosh i think the old ones weren't
supposed to be funny but they just were
the old ones were just supposed to cash
ins on the on the name
somebody said that witchy poo from hr
puff and stuff used to freak him out
yeah that's pretty that's kind of scary
that was like a [ __ ] acid trip of a
machine it was
that was hr puff and stuff
and [ __ ] sigmund in the cmos yeah all
all of those old
[ __ ] shazam too uh [ __ ]
actually the best one for me actually
was land of the lost you could watch it
on youtube
and i loved land of the world landlord
lost with me so much i didn't realize
how
fast melinda lost him yeah progressed
forward
like i'm like i remember the story oh i
remember the story dude on three i'm
three episodes
into this [ __ ] they're so short yeah
they're like they're like 15 minutes
late that [ __ ] already happened three
episodes into the [ __ ]
but uh yeah once you take the
commercials out they're only 15 minutes
long yeah i think they're like 15 18
minutes but um
the sleeve stacks were my favorite and i
love that [ __ ] pylon [ __ ] with all
the like colored buttons and
yeah i love that hr puff and stuff and
the [ __ ] monkeys were made under the
influence of [ __ ] not the monkeys
what was that other one it was kind of
like the monkeys
hr puff and stuff it might have been the
monkeys
they were made under the influence of
[ __ ] lsd you gotta be [ __ ]
tripping
clearly to [ __ ] i think it was i
think i'm thinking of the monkeys well
the monkeys they did that movie they
were in a car
ahead yeah that was like kind of a drug
movie
it wasn't for kids though yeah monkeys
wasn't so much for kids there's another
one that's kind of like the monkeys that
i'm thinking of that was
wait are you talking about a band or a
show it was a show
uh it was um show but for some reason
i'm associating it with like kind of
like the monkeys
was it uh it was banana split banana
splits that's exactly what i'm thinking
of
banana splits for some reason that got
crossed
across but it was hr puffing up puffing
stuff
and banana splits were [ __ ] they were
done they were engineered that whole
thing was designed
on [ __ ] heavy lsd let's make a kids
program
yeah okay here let's drop them from here
and they drop and wait that 45 minutes
for the [ __ ] to kick
in okay what we're gonna do is we're
gonna have a big dragon
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we're
gonna have some mushrooms yeah
there's mushrooms all over that [ __ ]
yeah man and then there's gonna be a
bunch of kids and they're playing and
monsters everything's friendly
yeah baby sass is gonna be there
yeah yeah that's that's how that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
number if you guys don't know who baby
says
i like sigmund of the sea monsters a
while back
in the 90s there was an actually an
album that came out that was called
saturday morning and it had like all
these 90s indie bands like covering like
all of those
what can i talk or are you just gonna
like
no
what about it the gayest man to have
ever lived ripped torn
remember that yeah on sigmund sea
monster that [ __ ] had me had me
[ __ ] just
entertained every time he would show wow
he'd be throwing glitter and [ __ ] he
dressed up like the sea king
yeah wasn't that wasn't that his [ __ ]
i think it was he was kind of like the
uncle
arthur of [ __ ] the show he would just
appear out of nowhere and [ __ ] start
solving [ __ ] but i was a little kid when
i saw it
yeah and it just yeah that's not real
rick is a different guy that guy is
ripped
taylor rip taylor that's right rip
riptorn is another
that's what his name was yeah he had the
glitter yeah glitter and a big old
[ __ ] mustache
that's what happened and he had the
[ __ ] big old [ __ ]
hair dude look like mod yeah that old
lady damn haircut
there should have been curlers in it or
something that'd be funny
yeah [ __ ] you know
[Laughter]
that was a great show man he was wasn't
he on hollywood squares a lot yeah
i feel like he was on hollywood squares
a lot yeah him and phyllis diller and
that's right he he was like a copy of
phyllis diller
he was like the male female yeah i think
he was [ __ ] ripping phyllis diller
off
you know that was a good time man it was
a good time
it's so weird how like what weird
celebrities we had
yeah like charo and all that kind of
[ __ ] yeah it's so funny because like
kids today they're all [ __ ] worried
they didn't think there was any what
they call today they would call it the
lgbt
[ __ ] representation oh you're full of
[ __ ] man well they just didn't call it
that
they didn't call it that 70s tv was just
gay as [ __ ] man
everybody was gay on that [ __ ] and
they were some of the greatest [ __ ]
they were the greatest entertainers of
all times
you know [ __ ] liberace uh
paul [ __ ] man
if you were going to go up against that
dude man you [ __ ]
he would [ __ ] you up he would say some
[ __ ]
he was [ __ ] awesome yeah he was just
go back and watch the hollywood squares
with [ __ ] paul lind on it
he would have you rolling and he was
loaded through the whole [ __ ] show
you could see them most of them were
yeah they would you could see them
they would turn around like do this
because they'd be filling up their
drinks
like our show just like our show we've
talked about it before they'd be filling
up their drinks then they get back to
doing the hollywood squares
because they'd be in there all day and
making those making each little [ __ ]
episodes
and sometimes they'd do like seven
episodes eight episodes a day and then
by the eighth episodes they were just
[ __ ] up and they had another one and
[ __ ]
uh had characters like that it was a
[ __ ] game show called
the liars club you could see that [ __ ]
on youtube the liars
some of those things that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] great they'd have these [ __ ]
six liars
or seven liars up there they were
[ __ ] comedians and actors and
you just they were always change them
around and they'd give them an object
that you really couldn't identify
and the dude would take the object
because you see what this is
is this is a birth control test
you know what i mean just you put a frog
inside this and then the woman sits on
table you put that up there like then if
the frog dies
she's pregnant and then passes it down
to the next one and the other one tells
a lie about it and only one of them's
telling truth
i remember that yeah and uh and you have
to
the contestants have to bet on who's
telling the truth or who's lying i for
oh
yeah on who's telling the truth and
that's how you want to kind of some of
you guys might that and they would be
[ __ ]
blasted they'd have what was buddy
hackett on there
yeah and on some of those episodes buddy
hackett could barely talk
hey but he was still just funny as [ __ ]
drunker
buddy heck it got the funnier he was
he was [ __ ] great because they
couldn't censor is that they would they
couldn't
control him yeah he would say [ __ ] that
was just looking off the wall
they'd bleep it out i think they bleeped
it out retroactively because i think
some of that [ __ ] was live it's on a
delay so that's what they do with the
live tv for exactly that reason yeah
they just couldn't control him you know
when once he got it there's a few
seconds delayed so if somebody swears or
somebody says some of that [ __ ] was
bleep and then you hear the audience
just [ __ ] just
roaring with laughter for some reason i
don't for some reason i have fond
memories of joker's wild
you guys remember yeah yeah i liked that
i think there was something i really
liked about like the big lever
and like the the noise that it made like
i was really into that i don't know
why yeah somebody [ __ ] somebody
throughout paul lynde before we
mentioned
yeah they do is [ __ ] great am i
remembering it wrong but
didn't he voice templeton the rat
in the charlotte's web adaptation the
animated one
like i feel like that was him now i have
to go back and check
i don't know that was a good cartoon i
was i saw that like a milk yeah he died
aids sex didn't he um did he he might
have
he died under some kind of circumstance
that it was cancer it was something like
he
he died before his time yeah yeah
if some bad [ __ ] happened to paul paul
brought some
young dude to his place and [ __ ] they
were loaded on something and
when he came back in to see the guy was
out on the ledge
drinking he says you better come back in
the ledge to the ledge of his apartment
the ledge was about three feet wide you
could get out on it
yeah and the dude fell off the [ __ ]
ledge to his [ __ ] death oh
my god it was like [ __ ] 11 stories or
something that's [ __ ] up
yeah and he wasn't charged or anything
it was oh yeah
yeah he didn't do anything he was drunk
dude got out on a ledge
because it seemed like a good idea at
the time yeah
and evidently that guy's death he didn't
never really kind of
recover from him well you can't blame
him kind of blamed himself pretty
horrible i think he felt bad and he kind
of blamed himself for that dude falling
off
it was a young guy you know in his 20s
he was he was a [ __ ] player in the
gay clubs you know what i mean uh he
he was real famous and he didn't really
have as much money as people thought
that he did he spent a lot of money too
but he was real well known in the la
scene and
um he was popular with the young guys
and
that was one a guy he wouldn't regularly
hook up with
and evidently he did have some drug
problems uh
yeah that's what um victor said google
said he died of massive heart attack due
to substance abuse
who uh paul paul yeah
that was a [ __ ] rough time you know
[ __ ] there was a lot of drugs in l.a
at that
that time and that was the place where
you wanted to be if you were gay you
wanted to be there
yeah and uh the dudes [ __ ] ran that
[ __ ] into the ground
yeah you know i feel like kind of the
70s
70s um you know everybody was just like
doing everything to access your success
and then it just kind of caught up with
everybody see the movie boogie
yeah the villages people the village
people was happening in 3d
[Laughter]
well i mean everyone was like coped out
everyone was like just sleeping with
everybody
huge porn scene yeah [ __ ] uh because
nobody was worried about it then nobody
knew about aids nobody knew
about nope you know but it was just like
partying like parties tomorrow yeah it
was [ __ ]
california was [ __ ] babylon you know
and when i was a little kid you know you
go to [ __ ] i told this before in the
store you know in other parts of the
show
you know uh my aunt lois [ __ ] take us
up to the [ __ ] um and read you know
they
take us up to the [ __ ] sequoia
redwood forest you know
and i'd be walking around [ __ ] 11 12
years old or whatever
a group of [ __ ] 16 year old girls
would [ __ ] just walk around the
corner of the [ __ ]
walk around in on you know walk right by
you on a path to the [ __ ] lake just
butt ass naked just nudism you know
yeah they lay out there [ __ ] these
are underage girls you know [ __ ]
adults around everything
they'd lay out there you know [ __ ]
smoking weed and
then the rangers would come and play
[ __ ]
john denver [ __ ] music on the [ __ ]
rocky mountain high colorado and all
that [ __ ]
i need rolling joints and giving out it
was just another time
it was another [ __ ] world it was
it was just the safety of being up there
it was a real safe scene at that time
yeah i heard it's changed but that's the
way it was until everything went to hell
well i heard that [ __ ] drug cartels
are up there in those mountains growing
[ __ ]
drugs so it got more dangerous yeah
but i don't know if that's true or not
that's just what i heard i heard that
you couldn't you can't get away with the
[ __ ] you used to be able to get away
with in the 70s
well and the culture has changed well
and plus in the 70s you had all these
serial killers running around
particularly in california they didn't
know though
yeah it took them a lot it took what
peop i remember hearing about that [ __ ]
when i was a kid and it took
decades for that to sink in to the
american mind
that that was something that could
happen to you yeah because during that
same time
that i'm telling you all this is in the
late 70s mid to late 70s very early 80s
14 and 15 year old girls would [ __ ]
hitchhike and jump right into a car with
a stranger
well yeah it wasn't weird they didn't
think anything about it
people did it all the time yep and it's
like i think that it didn't really like
occur to people until maybe the late 70s
or early 80s it's like oh hey maybe
we're getting in a car with a weirdo and
you need to murder us because that does
happen
and looking back at it there was no real
in california at that era there was no
real concept of [ __ ] underage
uh there just wasn't you were either a
child or an adult there really wasn't
any kind of a teenage
defense years which is almost kind of
like something i'd see in brazil
too you know yeah because looking back
on it a lot of those 15 16 year-old
girls were running with dudes that were
in their 20s and 30s
it didn't seem unusual at the time yeah
it was just kind of like the common
culture
i mean i think even you know there are
pictures of david bowie and all these
guys running with these club girls and
you look at them they all look the same
but like one of them one of the most
famous one i think it was 14.
yeah but you look at her and she just
looks like somebody in her 20s
yeah yeah just another arrow you could
get away with a lot better yeah
another just did they didn't think they
didn't have the same
opinions it was like that in brazil too
yeah there were no there was no real
thing like a teenager
you know especially out in the favela
yeah like once you were old enough once
you were all enough to work you were
you won't have to do anything you know
yeah i was going to the [ __ ] clubs
and bars at you know 15. because you
could you could afford it so they'd let
you in
yeah yeah and there were other ones in
there it didn't matter
and uh you know
girls from the favela 15 16 years old
[ __ ] you know
says streetwalkers prostitutes and stuff
you know they just and prostitute
prostitution was illegal
but it just wasn't enforced so you know
yeah there's no way they could control
it it was a lot it was a lawless
state you know it's a lawless country
yeah probably still that way
probably yeah they had laws but there's
just no way to enforce them no will to
enforce any laws yeah there's like
they're like yeah who gives a [ __ ]
totally
totally demoralized country in that way
yeah mango badger says jimmy page was
involved with the girl that you just
mentioned yeah the girl what was her
name again i can't remember what her
name was
i think we mentioned her when we did the
show about uh
about that house like one of the most
famous
club girls from studio 54. like
everybody knew her
everybody was dating her off and on she
dated celebrities and stuff and i think
she was
15 14 15 16 when she when she was
hit that scene but she didn't look that
she didn't look like 14 50 60. she just
she looked like she was like 20.
yeah you know and the age evidently
wasn't
an issue well i guess if you looked old
enough yeah they just okay whatever
yeah it's weird different time nowadays
they'd lock your ass up for that [ __ ]
yeah they would yeah they're talking
about hitchhiking
yeah yeah it just seemed like it wasn't
weird i don't know
like people didn't really seem to think
it was all that dangerous and like i
said
most of the time it wasn't because
millions of people hitchhiked and like
you know yes people got killed by serial
killers and stuff but that was still
fairly rare even though the 70s was kind
of like 70s and 80s were kind of like
the heyday
but i just i don't know if people just
didn't really think about it yeah laurie
maddox was her name
yeah yeah that's right i don't know if
people didn't think about it or didn't
occur to them that it was dangerous or
you know yeah because i would never
[ __ ] dream of doing that [ __ ]
even when i was a kid i wouldn't have
done that all right so yeah we've been
going on promise an hour
yeah it's time to shut it down all right
well thanks for joining us and uh yeah
go ahead and watch that movie
yeah we're gonna like i said there's
another new one on shutter too so i'll
probably watch that tonight and we might
watch it beyond the door too if you want
yeah we'll get back to you guys
and then uh we'll probably stream again
tomorrow same time
same channel probably three o'clock yep
so uh we'll see you again tomorrow
bye